good morning believe nation today's
message is discover your strength over
um Ron cotton a leader and all of your
future leaders you must not accept this
you must not take the trodden path you
have to to become a leader you have to
face resistance no one has ever ever
achieved anything if they haven't faced
failures if they haven't had
disappointments if they haven't had days
when they don't want to wake up get out
of bed no no one has ever achieved
anything to achieve anything in life you
have to be prepared to take on the odds
face disappointment but all of you do
not realize that all of us the Almighty
has given tremendous strength which lies
within us you only discover that
strength when you put yourself up
against resistance if you don't face
resistance that strength lies dormant
within you the moment you take on
challenges you will then start
discovering this the enormous strength
you have in you so when you go on the
trodden path you will never accept this
strength I think a lot of entrepreneurs
think is gonna be too easy
I think people start a business and I
think it's going to be way easier than
it is I think some people just go
anything is gonna be easy straight up I
think some people go in thinking it's
gonna be hard but yeah I'm not that hard
and I'm smart and I'll be able to do it
and they massively underestimate the
amount of work persistence patience
that's required to turn a successful
business they mean look at I'm gonna be
I want to be youtuber I want to be the
next youtuber I'm gonna have an insane
channel I'll be a YouTube celebrity and
then they start making videos and it
doesn't doesn't take off they don't get
come so don't get used you can't expect
to get massive results from doing your
first shot at something like you need to
practice you need to get better you need
to have more love for what you're doing
you need to create work that you want to
show your grandkids you need to have
more persistence you need to make
yourself better
you got to work you got to practice and
that's where you discover your strength
and I think the only way to do it is if
you're doing something that you love if
you're doing it because you love it if
you enjoy the work you enjoy the process
and you're not chasing some goal if
that's what you're doing you're going to
have success sooner or later you're
going to have success and it's the only
way like you don't see people hit the
top in any field without loving what
they do this between a CEO and a middle
manager at a business is the CEO loves
what they do it's not just about playing
politics it's not just about playing the
game they love what they do and the
middle manager meals it in it doesn't
work as hard you know lives for the
weekends and evenings because they don't
love what they do and in the
Entrepreneurship world the people who
really have a big impact people who
create empires people who shape the
world are the ones who deeply love what
they do you know Steve Jobs up here on
the wall loves what he did he was a
multi-millionaire in his early 20s worth
over a hundred million dollars if it was
30 and worked till the day he died doing
something that he loved that drive for
impact that drive to create things is
what motivated him and yes he got paid
along the way for me I love helping
entrepreneurs the way I'm doing it right
now is to my youtube channel and when
I'm connecting with entrepreneurs it
just makes me come alive when I travel
it's one of the things that I love doing
most is meeting with you guys and
understanding your business and trying
to help you out and trying to inject
some believe and some creativity and
just motivation to keep going I love it
like I could do it all day long and
forget to go to the bathroom and forget
to eat and then just pass out because I
love it right and I would do it even if
it wasn't getting paid to do it and to
survive I would do other things to make
money just keep focusing on this until
it became something that I could make
money with it's gonna be hard and your
strength will be tested and you're gonna
give up unless you love absolutely love
the work that you're doing
so the question day today is I'm curious
what do you love most about what you do
in your business what's a single thing
inside your business that makes you come
alive the most leaving the comments
below and I will join in the discussion
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Richard Owen Richard thank you so much
for ordering my book it means a lot to
me for your chance to get a
in a future video make sure you pick a
copy of the book and then email us your
receipt thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso